[Music]
beethoven's third concerto third
movement
[Music]
okay so the first thing is that you need
to focus on the fourth and fifth fingers
[Music]
and the basic pattern is an octave
with
a lower neighbor tone
from the top
[Music]
so there's that little crunch note
leading up to
[Music]
e flat
[Music]
so
to practice it
[Music]
blocking both the upper two notes
all three
two
reverse it play the octave first and
then
the crunch note
[Music]
maybe start with
transposing in different keys
[Music]
d
[Music]
b flat
[Music]
that's a little difficult
[Music]
here's another one for scarecrow number
two descending our pleasures
[Music]
looking at measure 442
that might be tricky
[Music]
first of all i would be very mindful of
the difference between this one
going to the a
and this one
going to the b because naturally you
want to be doing
the same so that's why it's a little
tricky
[Applause]
and then be mindful of the position of
[Music]
the fourth finger
the pitches rather
[Music]
now accent those
[Music]
maybe try something like this
[Music]
you